[Music]
[Music]
the evil within two's more open-ended
nature leaves a lot for you to discover
through exploration outside of optional
objectives and hidden caches are plenty
of Easter eggs for you to find some more
unexpected than others here are a
handful that we found during our first
time playing through evil within - but
I'm sure there are plenty more so add
the ones that we missed in the comments
below there might be some details in
this video about the game's story late
in the game so let's drop the spoiler
warning here okay let's go the original
evil within the letterbox look was a
hotly contested future upon release so
much so that the option to remove it was
patched in and it's not even an
available option in the sequel but the
evil within - gives a nod to its old
cinematic aspect ratio with a completely
optional moment that can be pretty easy
to miss you'll need to enter the house
in chapter 3 a seemingly normal house
you'll get locked into it once you try
to leave eventually you'll be
transported back to the old Beacon
mental hospital and the game will switch
to the originals letterbox look
you'll even get to relive an old
jump-scare from the first game but apart
from the callbacks to the original game
Wales does evil within to half well
other than some subtle nods to tango
GameWorks themselves you can see a
finger painted version of their logo on
the wall of Sebastian's daughter's room
the game also has some references to
other Bethesda franchises in the form of
some sweet collectibles the first one
you'll come across is from Wolfenstein
located in a truck in Chapter three open
up the rear end of this white semi here
and you'll discover a quote mysterious
machine which is not so mysterious if
you've ever played Wolfenstein the new
order
it's a Panzer whom the line of robotic
Nazi dogs they look great on my shelf so
here's when we get into a little bit of
spoiler territory the next few are later
in the game and during a dream sequence
in Chapter 12 you'll find a mysterious
symbol resting on the Shelf but I'm sure
you all know what this is it's the Elder
Scrolls online logo in chapter 13 as
you're running around town don't forget
to stop by this alleyway here because of
mysterious action figure is waiting for
you that's right the doom guy makes an
appearance and evil within two I'm just
a little disappointed you can't this
bump them also in chapter 13 when you
reach the sanctuary Hotel poke around
behind the reception desk because
there's another Easter Egg here that is
definitely not a mimic
you might recognize a logo on this mug
as it comes straight out of the game
pray take it keep it just make sure it
doesn't duplicate itself in the middle
of the night the last collectible you'll
encounter is all the way near the end of
the game as you return to the house one
last time check the bookshelf over here
and pick up the mysterious toy you may
recognize this dude as the keeper one of
the enemies from the previous game who
was once a hulking menace but now looks
a lot less threatening as a 6-inch
plastic doll while we found these little
toys to populate our room with the only
Bethesda franchise that we seem to be
missing is fallout I'm sure there just
has to be one hitting the game somewhere
so if you find it posting in the
comments below oh and before you go
here's possibly one final call-out to
another game the credit union in the
business district is subtitled Sons of
Liberty this is most likely a reference
to none other than the United States
founding fathers revolt against British
taxation on the colonies but since we're
talking about video games here let's
just say it's a reference to the
terrorist organization featured in Mel
Gear Solid 2 kind of a downgrade for
them to be running a bank now but hey
when times are tough and grotesque
monsters are taking over the town you
gotta do what you gotta do so those were
all the Easter eggs that we found on our
first playthrough of the evil within -
make sure to check out the review of the
game on GameSpot calm and if you find
any other Easter eggs or references to
other games while playing the evil
within - let us know in the comments
below
my name is Joey thanks for watching